welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spiderman no way home released
an official poster to which they invited
us to zoom in on those details oh boy
challenge accepted cause that fiery face
in the bottom left corner has been
seared into my inner eyelids every time
i fall asleep accompanied by the sounds
of swarming locusts and the screams of
everyone i love just kidding as we have
learned in the mcu glowing faces
smashing up through the ground beneath
their feet are just baby celestial scene
it ain't the devil but it is mephisto
this poster while a bit straightforward
on the surface actually poses
interesting questions about what moment
in spider-man no way home this is
representing and why we are seeing so
much of peter in the iron spider armor
so after i have broken down cakes tom
hardy's hat in elizabeth olsen's
gardening videos breaking down details
you missed on this poster is as routine
as pouring a normal cup of coffee
another place his face likes to jump out
at me now the detail they clearly want
us to find is our first official look at
green goblin norman osborne willem dafoe
in the mcu he rides the glider that he
rode in the sam raimi films and wears
the same terrifying helmet you can also
see him clutching a pumpkin grenade
suggesting this might be representing
the moment that we've seen in the
trailer where that bomb bounces on the
bridge as green goblin laughs in the
background
indeed if you look closely at the
surface spider-man is crouching upon the
crumbled concrete with the rebar with
doc ock's arms clawing up toward peter
this is likely that bridge battle where
peter in the iron spider armor gets
attacked by both doc ock and green
goblin now there was an earlier leak of
this poster printed on the side of a bus
in australia showing similar framing but
instead of a simple sky background the
manhattan skyline curved into a donut in
the mirror dimension as we see elsewhere
in the trailer but this version includes
green goblin among other clues but green
goblin's so tiny looky little goblin
junior gonna cry no seriously willem
dafoe has committed too hard to this
role to be relegated to so little real
estate you know how much i sacrifice i
think this poster was designed this way
intentionally to leave negative space in
which they can later add in more
elements maybe bring green goblin closer
and closer because remember early promo
materials for avengers in-game also left
some blank spots and shots because they
didn't want to give the full context of
everyone who would be in this scene of
the movie this poster also shows some
yellow lightning bolts like the ones in
the trailer that we have attributed to
electro jamie foxx whose bolts in this
movie have been recolored from blue to
yellow after the amazing spider-man 2
yellow being more of a yellow and green
on brand color for the character of
elektro and then you can also see some
trails of sand which almost seemed to
make out the shape of an s left by
sandman of course who will be returning
in this movie last seen in sam rainey
spider-man 3 played by thomas hayden
church really the only villain missing
from this poster is rhys iphone's lizard
from the 2012 film who does briefly
appear swiping at peter in the trailer
now another difference from that bus
poster was peter's extended iron spider
arms which seemed to be retracted here
or just missing brings up the big
question of why we keep seeing peter in
this iron spider suit and all the promo
footage for spider-man no way home when
really the suit he designed and far from
home is technically newer well to me
it's obvious that peter would need
heavier duty nanotech armor and extra
arms to face doc ock tom holland teased
in an interview that the combat of this
movie is going to be more visceral than
in the past and really the most visceral
we've seen this spider-man get was in
avengers end game when he finally
activated instant kill mode and these
mechanized arms went to town on the dog
piling outriders activate instant kill
i think using the same function is his
best chance to keep up with doc ox arms
but that would also mean that peter
suited up with this armor in this scene
going to the trouble of removing it from
its nuclear charging unit in his bedroom
means he expected to face doc ock in
this moment so this encounter on the
bridge might not be the first time he
witnessed doc ock after doctor strange's
spell warped reality or after it was
warped through any of the other reasons
that it could have been warped thanks to
hellofresh for sponsoring this video get
mouthwatering seasonal recipes and fresh
pre-measured ingredients delivered right
to your door with hellofresh america's
number one meal kit hellofresh makes
cooking at home fun easy and affordable
as fall transitions into winter there's
nothing better than cozying up with a
comforting home-cooked meal recipes like
chicken ramen and shoyu style broth and
turkey ragu gnocchi make it a no-brainer
to skip on pain for takeout i just love
the variety that hellofresh offers they
have 50 menu and market items to choose
from every week including vegetarian
calorie smart and gourmet options i get
to try new recipes all the time i
chopped my zucchinis peeled the garlic
zested the lemon
um so i'm
well on my way to making this yum yums
there we go
whoa baby
almost done and then i got the uh garlic
yummy lemony stuff going over here
pasta pasta please hello fresh has more
five star reviews than any other meal
kit so you know you're getting something
delicious in every delivery go to
hellofresh.com
rockstars14 and use code rockstars14 for
up to 14 free meals and three free gifts
now some folks taking this tweets
challenge have gone admirably apeshit on
doc ock's arms finding a circular gray
region on his uppermost pincer that they
claim is a face but to me the only face
that could be is the nightmare face of
thomas the tank engine
really i think this is just a common
case of peridolia that's the tendency to
see faces or other familiar shapes and
otherwise chaotic or just random noise
which would also explain what is going
down in the bottom left corner now to be
clear i love mephisto i pledge to him my
internal loyalty in the soul of my
firstborn child don't tell kelly i did
that please but when mephisto arrives in
the mcu and yes it is a win it's not
gonna be as a fiery half-face in the
corner of a poster like serious
black with this movie taking some
inspiration at least from one more day
and its follow-up story one moment in
time there is at least a chance mephisto
could tie into these events but i would
say if he does appear here it would more
likely take the form of like a little
kid or a voice from the shadows or some
goofy stunt casting ultimately i find
far more interesting the possibility
that doctor strange could be under the
influence of someone like the scarlet
witch despite how much apparently the
idea of strange being overpowered by
anyone triggers some of you only because
one of vision made it explicitly clear
that wanda's powers exceed those of the
sorcerer's supreme and kevin feige
himself has repeatedly stated that wanna
maximoff is the msu's most powerful
character at the moment but if we are
looking clues inside doc ock's arms they
do appear more condensed here whereas
that empire magazine photo showed them
outstretched with daylight visible
between the joints but in this and other
shots of the appendages there appears to
be some kind of red or gold inlay
between those joints which some have
interpreted as doc ock possibly having
nanotech that could have broken off and
absorbed peter's iron spider arms into
his own i'm not sure about that like if
his arms already have nanotech why would
he need to absorb some of peter parker's
nano attack how would that make them
stronger but here's what i really find
interesting about doc ox arms in this
poster you can see exactly three of doc
ock's four arms visible one two and
three so where's the fourth arm what is
that fourth arm doing who or what could
the fourth arm be clutching to threaten
peter is that fourth arm taking the
photo that we are seeing really i do
think peter parker's iron spider armor
will be destroyed in this film along
with his other suits becoming unusable
which will force him into a new suit
that he will customize to be compatible
with doctor strange's sorcery i mean
that just tends to be the life cycle of
every bit of tech in the mcu it gets
engineered to deal with whatever the
current threat is and then when they try
to bring into the next movie that next
threat pushes it beyond its limits which
necessitates literal evolution for the
character's technology like a hermit
crab finding a new shell which mirrors
their own spiritual evolution in some
way look folks a new trailer for
spider-man no way home is likely days
away or may already be in the world by
the time you watch this video so brace
yourselves we're gonna get new footage
to actually break down though in the
meantime obviously our imaginations are
active enough to enjoy the movie just
fine without having any new footage to
break down hey to support this channel
check out one of our great merch options
at newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow
me on instagram and twitter at ea boss
follow new rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars breakdowns everything marvel
thank you for watching and
eric fuss
tell them who i am
[Music]
you